[Music]
on this Wednesday night Israeli troops
raid gaza's largest Hospital medical
staff scramble to protect
patients what Israel claims it's found
and what gaza's critical shortage of
fuel means for Aid workers plus the
sharp response from Israel's prime
minister to Justin trudo's call to
exercise maximum
restraint a mission to make amends the
high stake Summit between the presidents
of the US and China and their goal goes
beyond
winning the soccer fans trying to
reclaim the beautiful game plus foul
conclusion how a barfing bird was just
voted bird of the
century global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us Israel warned it would Target
gaza's largest hospital and 3 hours
before Dawn its soldiers swept in in
what it calls a precise and targeted
Mission the Israeli Army released this
video its tanks rolling towards Al shifa
Hospital in the darkness that hospital
is full of patients and medical staff
scrambled to move them to safety staff
say dozens of soldiers roam through the
emergency department and intensive care
ordering men between the ages of 16 and
40 to leave the
building military equipment there is a
an
AK-47 there are cartridges am ammo
are the IDF also released this video
which it says proves Hamas is using the
hospital as a terror headquarters we
can't verify the video Israeli
authorities have long claimed Hamas
operates its Command Center under Al
shifa Hospital staff say they have no
knowledge of that details of what
exactly happened inside the hospital are
limited the World Health Organization
says at one point it lost contact with
its Medics inside elifa our coverage
begins with Mike Armstrong and a warning
some of the pictures are
distressing in the chaos of Israeli
troops moving in on the shifa medical
complex a doctor on the ground says
staff was warned to stay away from
Windows as a result it's hard to tell
what's going on
outside but this video released by the
Hamas run Health Ministry appears to
show the commotion on the inside there
is
continuous shooting and firing outside
the hospital inside we not exactly
the staff and volunteers scramble to
move the 33 remaining premature babies
to another part of the complex three
have already died after power to their
incubators went
out now the Israeli Defense Force
released video it says shows soldiers
delivering Aid it says it's clearing
parts of the complex going room to room
and that several Hamas Fighters have
been killed but the IDF insists while
it's searching for Hamas and and
hostages it also has specialized teams
trained to help the IDF forces include
medical teams and Arabic speakers who
have undergone specified training to
prepare for this complex and sensitive
environment across the Gaza Strip at a
time when there is more need for medical
services than ever there are fewer and
fewer of those services available the
World Health Organization says of gaza's
3500 hospital beds only 1,400 are usable
21 of 35 hospitals have shut down they
are going into other buildings the
Palestinian prime minister says Israel
is waging a war on
hospitals while the head of un emergency
relief says he's appalled by what's
going on in and around hospitals I
understand the Israelis concern for
trying to find the leadership of Hamas
that's not our
problem now for the first time in weeks
Israel allow owed fuel into Gaza a
single truck moved in from Egypt
carrying diesel for the United Nations
the UN had said it needed fuel for its
Aid delivery trucks otherwise it would
have had to shut down its humanitarian
operations well the head of Unicef was
on the ground in conun Tuesday Katherine
Russell says to keep helping the
organization needs the fuel to keep
flowing and it needs a ceasefire so its
staff can move around most of the people
who work for Unicef in Gaza are from
Gaza um and they're so incredibly
courageous but they need to be able to
do their work safely now that one truck
of fuel was about 27,000 lers the UN
says it needs more than 10 times that
every day just to keep going what it's
seeing right now in Gaza it calls the
cascading collapse of essential Services
Donna all right Mike Armstrong in
Jerusalem thanks there are hostages
trapped in Gaza too and their families
worry they have been
forgotten
hundreds of relatives are Marching from
Tel Aviv to Jerusalem demanding Israel's
prime minister focus more on getting the
hostages released more than 200 people
were kidnapped during the October 7th
raid by Hamas on Southern Israel four
have been released one has been rescued
and Israel now confirms one woman a
19-year-old Israeli soldier has been
killed prime minister Justin Trudeau is
in San Francisco for the Apex Summit and
he's drawn a sharp response from
Israel's prime minister over his
assertion that Israel should show
maximum restraint in Gaza it's a topic
that may not be on the agenda of the
Apex Summit but it is certain to get
discussed David Aken is traveling with
the Prime
Minister prime minister Justin Trudeau
used his sternest language yet asking
the government of Israel to prosecute
its war against Hamas in a different way
I urge the government of Israel to
exercise maximum restraint the killing
of Women and
Children of
babies this has to stop Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu tagged
Trudeau in a post on social media saying
it is Hamas not Israel that should be
held accountable for committing a double
War crime targeting civilians while
hiding behind civilians the two men have
spoken by phone twice since the October
7th attacks and Canada has has not
changed its position that Israel has a
right to defend itself from Hamas still
Trudeau's unusually strong language and
netanyahu's response was unique it's
easier to go after uh a political Target
like Canada we don't have the same uh
material ability to underwrite Israel's
military campaign the way the US does
the Canadian government's position has
drawn strong
responses fire now Angry protesters made
their way into and gather gaed Tuesday
night outside a Vancouver restaurant
where Trudeau was eating prompting him
to leave because of security concerns
his office
said then nearly 100 police had to be
deployed when another group confronted
the PM later in the evening two people
were arrested on Wednesday Trudeau
headed to San Francisco for the annual
Summit of Pacific Nation leaders known
as Apec trudu was Keen to push Apec
countries to tackle the global
affordability Challenge and find ways to
lower food prices at home this is an
important discussion still with a war in
the Middle East and in Ukraine Apec
leaders may find it difficult to advance
trade and economic issues if this very
strong and dynamic group of countries
can find ways to integrate and to grow
and prosper then that leaves us all
better off this is going to be a quick
trip for the Prime Minister just two
nights and then back to Ottawa on Friday
Donna all right David Aken in San
Francisco tonight thanks ahead of the
Summit is a high stakes meeting between
the leaders of the world's two largest
economies the American President Joe
Biden sat down with China's president Xi
Jinping and she said the two countries
turning their backs on each other is not
an option Jackson frco on signs of a
relaxation in a tense relationship ready
this California Summit comes at a
fragile time with two superpowers locked
in a tense competition that could easily
lead to conflict I think it's Paramount
that you and I understand each other
clearly leader to leader with no
misconceptions or
miscommunication so much has happened
since Joe Biden and Xi Jinping last
shared a room one year
ago a Chinese surveillance balloon was
shot down over the US she struck up a No
Limits partnership with Russia's
Vladimir Putin and US support for Taiwan
LED China to sever official military
Communications at a time when there's
more Close Encounters than ever between
their armed for forces still she
suggested both countries can coexist if
they're allowed to chart their own paths
it is unrealistic for one side to
remodel the other and conflict and
confrontation has unbearable
consequences for both sides the summit
May deliver a slight thaw in this
otherwise Frosty relationship the two
biggest polluters on the planet agreed
to Triple renewable energy production by
2030 and China says it will better
regulate the chemicals used in the
production of f enol to help curve the
US opioid crisis I think this is more
about the Optics of the two leaders
trying to kind of reassure their
countries in the world that um that
they're not on a kind of War footing but
War could be a simple miscalculation
away especially over Taiwan and the
South China Sea where China continues to
flex its military muscle at an alarming
Pace the White House was quick to T down
hope for a major breakthrough suggesting
it believes the summit may open the door
enough for the US and China to talk
through their differences and at the
least agree to disagree for China this
is in many ways a reassurance tour that
will include an audience with top us
Business Leaders at a dinner in
California Executives will reportedly
pay $40,000 per table for a chance to be
in the same room as the leader of the
world's second largest economy Donna
Jackson prco in Washington thanks we
have an update tonight on a global news
investigation that found Canada has
become a safe haven for hundreds of
people connected to the Iranian regime
they're accused of threatening the lives
of some Canadians here yesterday
Global's [__] mahedi pressed the Prime
Minister for answers Nar Donna the
Islamic revolutionary guard Corps or
irgc is a powerful paramilitary
organization responsible for a lot of
the human rights violations in Iran I
asked the Prime Minister how he planned
to hold them accountable prime minister
will you commit to listing the irgc as a
terrorist entity we continue to watch
and make sure that we're able to do
everything we can that is responsible
against the impact of the irgc with all
due respect uh prime minister the people
who spoke to us you know they said that
they risked their lives just to speak to
us and they are desperate for a direct
answer from you could you please answer
my question will you list the irgc or
commit to listing the irgc as a
terrorist entity yes or no we will
continue to do everything necessary both
to hold that regime to account to limit
its impact around the world and to
protect Canadians regrettably he never
has an answer the irgc shot down Ukraine
International Airlines flight 752 in
2020 killing all 176 people on board
including 55 Canadian citizens and 30
permanent residents this lawyer says the
prime minister resorted to well-worn
talking points it's really a mystery as
to what else the IR rgc needs to do to
be listed as a terror group The irgc has
a documented record of killing Canadians
and killing people of other
nationalities besides you know the
repression at home when we press for a
simple yes or no on designating the irgc
a terrorist entity my mic was turned off
and I was politely told by Trudeau's
team that my time was up Donna all right
Nar mosti thank you a Manitoba man
killed in Ukraine coming up why he
volunteered to fight Russian forces
the world's Focus may have shifted from
the war in Ukraine but 21 months after
it started Russia is still on the attack
Ukrainian troops say they've now secured
a foothold on the Eastern Bank of the
Deno river that would be a significant
Advance opening a new route to Crimea
Ukraine's President Vladimir zalinski
says his soldiers are 70% of the way
there but Russia is not letting up
at least two more people were killed
today when a missile smashed into this
apartment Block in an eastern city Crews
raced to clear the debris and search for
survivors Russia has denied it is
targeting civilians among those joining
Ukraine's fight against Russia are
foreign Nationals including some
Canadians tonight a northern Manitoba
first nation is mourning the loss of a
crean who died fighting there Melissa
Rin spoke to his sister about his life
and death on a battlefield abroad
Austin llin bercier had an adventurer
spirit and humanitarian Soul he was
always like a community person like he
always liked going out like volunteering
he was in the Canadian Armed Forces
bolded Eagles as a teen a summer
training program for indigenous youth
from western Canada and Northwestern
Ontario with plans to join the
Infantry but while Laughlin burer was
traveling abroad in 2022 Russia invaded
Ukraine he felt he couldn't just stand
by while a sovereign country was
attacked by an authoritarian regime he
flew to Poland then crossed into Ukraine
to join the fight I think mainly he went
there because he seen like on the news
of how many innocent women and children
were being killed and for him like he's
always been protected of a women
children and even like those who
couldn't defend themselves or can't
defend themselves he kept loved ones
updated with texts and social media
posts his words to his mom all good here
two days later on Remembrance Day the
worst news my mom called me and let me
know that he was
gone Manitoba Premier wob Cano is among
the many calling the 25-year-old a hero
a pasque creation says he will be
honored as one I'm sure it's going to be
a big event not just from this community
but people the the armed services
community
and probably the Ukrainian Community
Laughin bier's family is coordinating
with the Canadian government for his
remains to return home to be buried next
to his grandmother Melissa ring Global
News
Winnipeg the UK's plan to send migrants
to Rwanda rejected ahead what the
British PM plans to do
[Music]
now parts of Eastern and northern France
are under a state of emergency tonight
widespread flooding has forced thousands
from their homes heavy rains have also
severely damaged roads meteorologists
say things are improving slightly now in
northern France but more rain is
expected in the coming days the UK's
highest court has ruled a government
plan to ship some Asylum Seekers to
Rwanda is unlawful the plan was intended
to deter migrants from crossing the
English Channel in small boats a
dangerous Journey that's led to hundreds
of deaths Britain's prime minister
though is still vowing plain loads of
migrants will leave leave for Rwanda as
planned in the spring our Europe bureau
chief Crystal ganing Reports on how he
plans to do that the rule of law is
fundamental to our democracy to stay
within the rule of law and stop the
boats as his Podium says Rishi sunak
will introduce new legislation
addressing he says the high Court's
findings that Asylum Seekers sent from
the UK to Rwanda could be wrongly
returned to the country in which they
were fleeing asking ourselves whether
there were substantial grounds for
believing that a real risk of Reform and
existed at the relevant time we have
concluded that there
were the conservatives Inked a deal with
Rwanda last year to fulfill a pledge to
stop illegal migration Minister
following the Supreme Court's ruling the
Prime Minister announced a new treaty
with Rwanda was in the works
guaranteeing in law those relocated from
the of the UK to the east African nation
will be protected from being removed
from Rwanda and the UK will bring back
anyone if a court mandates it plus
emergency legislation to confirm the new
treaty stating the UK deems Rwanda as
safe citing a track record of serious
human rights violations Amnesty
International issued a statement
labeling the Rwanda plan illc conceived
and cruel saying the government should
make policies which fit with the law not
fit the law around their policies it's
really important I think to bear in mind
that stopping the votes is just never
going to happen the government maintains
the policy is a deterrent and that
flights will depart this spring the
European Court of Human Rights could
still challenge the UK's reanda policy
Ed Home Secretary Su braan had
previously suggested the UK cut ties
with the court the prime minister is now
warning it not to get involved saying if
pressed he is willing to revisit
International relationships Crystal
ganing Global News
London more than a game next soccer fans
trying to rebuild the sports
[Music]
culture a vote in New Zealand is
ruffling some feathers thanks to a
global campaign started by a comedian
the P te techie has been crowned bird of
the century it's also known as the
australasian crested greeve it caught
the attention of John Oliver who said
what's not to love about the weird
puking bird with a colorful mullet so he
put up Billboards around the world
exploiting a loophole in the contest
that allows anybody with a valid email
address to vote more than
350,000 people from 195 countries did
that's over six times the previous
record and the PO Tech techie won in in
a landslide only about 3,000 of the
birds are believed to exist in the wild
and just a few more fun facts they eat
their own feathers to induce vomiting as
a way of expelling parasites there you
go and its song is a chorus of grunts
growls and Barks what's not to love
professional soccer players aim to be
the best in the world and the greatest
scorers make hundreds of millions a year
now a group of soccer fans in England
has decided to go back to the basics of
the beautiful game they pitch in to
rebuild their favorite local team and as
Redmond Shannon explains they did it
according to their own
values in the heart of Cockney East
London is the city's modern Olympic
Stadium home of billion dooll Premier
League soccer team West Ham United just
2 miles away is London's oldest senior
soccer
field the old spotted dog ground home of
Clapton Community FC both are part of
England's vast pyramid of connected
leagues but the ways they run are a
million miles apart when these big teams
and the fans say oh we won I said no no
no they they won you watched when we win
we do win because we own the club we
have ownership make that 1,600 co-owners
part of a small but growing movement
among soccer fans who want their game
back after a split with the previous
team owner over ticket prices these fans
reformed the historic Club putting
Community into its name entry is now
about $7 concessions work on a
trust-based system the whole project
part financed by a unique shirt design
that unexpectedly went viral in Spain it
was a shirt that was in the colors of
the second Spanish Republic the shirt is
in homage to the international brigades
who came from across the globe to
support the war against Fascism and we
sold in one day
148,000 worth of sales and shirts yes
this is a step seven Club but we sold
that many in just one day the new club
started women's teams for the first time
giving them equal funding to men and
campaigning for better female prize
money it also has Open Access teams for
people of all of abilities it's not
about showing your skills it's more
about Community being together
encouraging each other being really
supportive and we all learning together
bucking the hooligan stereotype the team
welcomes refugees and trans players and
has zero tolerance on hate speech yeah
just like a much more inclusive way to
go and see football and it's a nice sort
of antithesis to what the sort of the
the high levels of football have become
winning or losing is secondary to a
sense of community
and for many it's even a sense of family
Redmond Channon Global News
London and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna freezen
tonight's your Canada is leech's Creek
on Cape Britton Island Nova Scotia we'd
love to see your Canada especially
wintry photos as it is mid November
please email them to viewers at
global.com and thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]